hallo pascal endlich fliegen wir in den
urlaub
freust du dich
ja das wird toll
wir müssen in einer halben stunde zum
flughafen losfahren
müssen in einer halben stunde zum
nehmen wir
taxi
ja wir fahren in 30 minuten los
ich freue mich sehr auf unsere reise
nach berlin
ich
freue mich sehr auf unsere reise nach
berlin
hast du deinen
reisepass mitgenommen
hast du deinen reisepass mitgenommen
ja mein reisepass ist in meinem
handgepäck
super ohne reisepass dürfen wir nicht in
den urlaub fliegen
super ohne
reisepass dürfen wir nicht in den urlaub
fliegen
[Musik]
der flughafen hier in zürich ist so groß
ja es ist immer toll hier zu sein
was müssen wir zuerst machen
wir müssen zum check in schalter gehen
wir
zum check in schalter gehen
dort bekommen
unseren boarding pass
und können und
pack abgeben
heck abgeben
ok sehr gut
schauen wir nach zu welchem
check-in-schalter wir gehen müssen
[Musik]
wir nach zu welchem check-in-schalter
wir gehen müssen
wir müssen zum
schirm mit den informationen gehen
wir müssen zum bildschirm mit den
informationen gehen
dort
wohin wir gehen müssen
steht wohin wir gehen müssen
wir müssen zum terminal 1 zum schalter
15 gehen
das ist gleich hier in der nähe
guten tag wohin fliegen sie
kennen sie mir bitte ihre reisepässe
geben
guten tag wir fliegen nach berlin
vielen dank
haben sie alle flüssigkeiten in ihrem
aufgabe gepäck
im handgepäck sind keine flüssigkeiten
erlaubt
außerdem müssen alle batterien von
kameras
oder sonstigen elektronischen geräten im
handgepäck sein
wir haben alle flüssigkeiten im aufgabe
gepäck
alle flüssigkeiten im aufgabe gepäck
alle elektronischen geräte sind im
handgepäck
perfekt vielen dank
[Musik]
hier haben sie ihre boarding pässe
gehen sie bitte zur sicherheitskontrolle
danach gehen sie zum geht 35
das boarding beginnt um 14 uhr 40
dank
wir gehen sofort zur
sicherheitskontrolle
guten tag
bitte alle elektronischen geräte
und kleinen flüssigkeiten auspacken
vielen dank
ich habe kein handgepäck dabei
ich habe mein gepäck abgegeben
vielen dank
dann wünsche ich ihnen noch einen
angenehmen flug
ich habe auch kein handgepäck dabei
ich habe
auch kein handgepäck dabei
dankeschön
[Musik]
ihnen auch einen guten flug
toll wir sind schon bald beim geht
wir sind schon bald beim geld
wir haben noch 30 minuten zeit
möchtest du hier noch etwas im duty free
shop kaufen
hier ist ja alles günstiger
hier muss man keine steuern bezahlen
ich weiß
wir können nach dem rückflug etwas
kaufen
ja ich bin deiner meinung
lasst uns zum gate gehen es ist spät
[Musik]
wir haben es rechtzeitig geschafft
jetzt können wir ins flugzeug gehen
und endlich nach berlin fliegen
ja das wird eine tolle erfahrung
müssen wir für das boarding alles
vorbereiten
was müssen wir für das boarding alles
ich glaube wir brauchen nur unseren
reisepass
guten tag
ihren reisepass und ihren boarding pass
bitter
bitte
bitteschön bitte
vielen dank
ich wünsche ihnen einen angenehmen flug
ihre sitzplätze sind 4 a und 4 b
vielen dank
toll alles hat super geklappt und wir
hatten keinen stress
alles hat super geklappt und wir hatten
keinen stress
jetzt können
er endlich nach berlin fliegen
jetzt können wir ein
ich nach berlin fliegen
ja lasst uns ins flugzeug einsteigen
berlin wir kommen
abonniere den kanal der halo deutsch
schule
aktiviert
das kleine glöckchen
gib uns jetzt einen daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese playlist um weitere
videos zu sehen